there's people watching right and we've
already like messed up at the beginning
and it like cuts and it's just me a
cinematographer and Ellen being like oh
God oh God oh God oh God oh God and like
cursing and being like okay we're live
again in 30 seconds here we go
when did you decide you were going to be
not only the lead actress and night
mother but also a producer
oh man that that whole thing feels like
a fever dream at times
um I'll tell you the story of it so it's
20 20. and the film industry has shut
down and died and we are all out of a
job right like all of a sudden
everything was halted we're at home
that's all by July I was like as fun as
this is I'm dying inside because for me
since this is my calling if I don't get
to do it every day I really do feel like
I'm atrophying so I was like well okay I
can at the very least work on something
I can become better as an artist and
work on my craft so I reached out to a
friend of mine a really dear friend from
my Opera days Ellen McLean who super
internationally famous voice actor she
was GLaDOS in Portal and Portal 2 and
voice is like half the characters in
Dota 2. she's voiced an incredible body
of work and is an amazing woman and also
was an opera singer so she was my my
boss for like a small local Opera gig in
Seattle
but I always admired her as an artist
and
reached out to her I was like hey let's
chat on Zoom sometime so we're chatting
and catching up and I was like you want
to just kick around to play like I would
love to just kind of work on character
and maybe look at this in a different
way so that when this time is up I'm not
just like well I was sad like something
came out of it
so she said sure yeah I love that that's
a great idea let's do it
let me think on that and the next time
we met she was like hey I found this
play it's perfect it's for two women
it's called night mother and I was like
whoa whoa because night mother was a
play that was there for me during a
really hard bout of my own depression
and there was this like lightning moment
that like kicked off where I was like if
we're gonna do this then we're gonna
actually do it we're gonna really do a
production and all of a sudden all these
things that I didn't realize I was
paying attention to kicked off and I
knew sort of how I wanted to do the
production
um side notes I people have been trying
to ask me to be a producer for many
years prior to this they could see that
I probably would be really good at it
and every time it's just no I'm not
interested in it I my concern was oh God
it's going to be the worst part of like
a middle school group project
and I really had no interest I was like
creatively I'm not sure that's something
I want to do
and I remember like people being like
produce your own content but I was
seeing a lot of actors do like vanity
content where it's like I want to be in
a western because I want to be in a
western I'm like great your short had no
substance and I'm very bored thank you
for that which sometimes I love vanity
content like it's fun to consume it's
fun to act in but producing no not so
much
so I was like whatever if I produce like
the right thing will come to me and I'll
know and this was that moment where I
was like well I'm going to produce
something apparently so
I you know we began working on it
and how I wanted to do it began to flesh
out of like okay the film rights were
already sold we clearly can't do a
standard movie of night mother because
that already exists and I think won an
Oscar so we can't touch that
um I don't want to do a play you know I
don't want to rent out a theater and do
it like that I want to do something
that's filmic so I started kicking
around this idea of a new type of
filmmaking and I I have a friend and
Mentor in Bernie Sue he has a show on
Twitch called artificial speaking of
really great sci-fi that I cannot
recommend enough and Bernie is just this
like really fascinating Cutting Edge guy
right like he he had he won the first
Emmy for a YouTube series and then he
won an Emmy for his twitch series and
now he's doing a tick tock series and so
he's always like kind of like pushing
the envelope with new innovative ways of
doing filmmaking
but like the way he did his series was
very much about audience input and so I
saw that and was like what if we put
that on its head and I used a platform
that was all about audience integration
but the audience doesn't get to
influence the story so it really is kind
of like a mix of both so I'm calling it
hybrid filmmaking because it really is
the best of live theater audience
integration platform and traditional
cinematic filming
um
it was this weird crazy Beast that was
really fun to play with in terms of
talking to Twitch and being like I have
two huge you know video game stars that
I'm working with you love having those
on your platform this is how to get
those on your platform so you are going
to do XYZ for us to which they said yes
of course
we ended up
um you know uh my my dear friend Sarah
uh who was my co-producer on the
production came up with this brilliant
idea to work with a bunch of mental
health focused non-profits so that we
could create a curated list of offerings
for our audience of like hey if you went
into crisis from the film here are
things you can get that are either free
or at a discounted rate so that you can
get care right now like are they kind of
walking the walk right because the cool
thing about audience integration with
your film is that you can actually care
for your audience in real time
um and it doesn't even have to be you
doing it right I was playing one of the
lead roles I was not able to be like
don't feel sad like let's talk about it
I was like in the zone fully in the
script so
um
we had to get really Innovative with
what we did we worked with this one
organization called take this
and specifically they they work their
non-profit about mental health in The
Gaming Community but they're they're
four deeply familiar with twitch so they
came on and they gave us
um live chat moderators as well as bots
so that the Bots and the live chat folks
could be like let's make sure we're
staying on topic but also identify if an
audience member went into crisis because
then they could pull them out into a
cool down room where they could then sit
with a licensed mental health counselor
and be like how are you can you do
something to ground yourself right now
so that we could actually take care of
our audience because so much of film is
like triggering
and then you're like I'm a raw wound I
guess I'm gonna go home and as a as a
creative that's not something I feel
particularly great about like I don't
want to just upset everyone I want it to
be like okay well here's where we
started and here's the movement that
follows I wanted to create a community I
wanted to create a platform I wanted
this to be more though than a one and
done experience I wanted it to be that
we would keep talking about it
um here we are over a year later talking
about it right
so it just it took on a life of its own
and it was everything that I loved about
collaboration like everyone who came on
board the project brought their own
Special Sauce that made it so much
better than anything I could have
imagined on my own and we really did
become an international movement I mean
we
we did better than I could have ever
possibly dreamed and really for me I
knew I wanted to make something because
it was 2020 and I was like oh my God
there's millions and millions of people
out there who've never felt depression
or anxiety or PTSD and they're learning
right now and they're trapped at home
alone what can I do to reach them and
that was what night mother was was a
piece you know a swan song of like let's
not be fluffy about suicide let's
actually shine a light at that shadow
and let's talk about it without pulling
any punches
and then once we've made it safe to talk
about that here are ways that you can
get care or at the very least find
support should you want it is night
mother a feature film it is a feature
film it is 64 minutes long so it kind of
barely qualifies as a feature
um
but yes it is it is we've we've cut it
significantly because the play itself I
think is like a two hour ordeal but
since we had moved it to an online
platform it just didn't make sense to
make people sit there for two hours you
know I didn't want to bring up like the
painful memories of a too long Zoom
meeting that we all have now been
through over the past couple years of
like God why won't it end so Alan is
just a masterful dramaturg and she just
lived with that script and just kept
cutting it cutting it cutting it until
it was the Bare Bones of what beats in
the story needed to be there so that the
story made sense from start to finish
again it's that whole
keeping it General but also very
specific so that someone coming in and
watching the story can relate to it
and the two of you are the only ones on
screen well occasionally there's
flashback sequences of other characters
but in terms of people actively speaking
it's just it was just Ellen and I and we
did the whole thing starts it was crazy
because they we did this on like was it
September 21st or 24th of 2021
um but we did it the whole thing start
to finish live where we performed it
start to finish live in front of a
studio audience it was recorded and
basically edited because our
cinematographer was like this man behind
the curtain dropping in these flashbacks
where he thought it made sense almost
like jazz music
so there was like this improvisatory
character almost of the flashbacks that
um was fun because Ellen and I we were
on a different platform that was being
run through into the twitch feed so
functionally it felt like a zoom call we
didn't see the audience we didn't see
any of that it was just me talking to
her which meant there was no pressure
really we just had to exist and live in
the script and live in that moment with
each other and hold space with each
other for 64 minutes
how did you feel about saying yes to it
I know you said that if you were going
to do it there was no stopping you but
then were there times where it did feel
like
it was triggering you oh my God yeah I
mean filmmaking and starting as a
filmmaker is like you are going to have
a lot of people come up and promise you
the moon and then not want to help you
because again a lot of people subscribe
to a really sad version of capitalism of
I have no interest in actually following
through and helping you with you and
your project and who cares if it never
happens
thank goodness I picked something that
was important to me because when the
going got tough if it wasn't I probably
would have dropped the project
um
producing is really really tough
in that you are going to have to deal
with a lot of BS on a lot of people who
it seems like exists just to make your
life hard
um
there's a lot of moving Parts you know
and a lot of
um gatekeeping I think a lot of folks
in our industry and Beyond who
aren't seeing the big picture
necessarily that I had to work through
as it were and so
yeah it can be really tough it can be
really really hard there were there were
more than a few times where I
was like okay I need to go vent to
someone because I I cannot throw the
towel in I have to tell the story I have
to finish this project and see it
through and I'm so glad that I did
so it wanted to fall apart on you many
times oh my God yeah I mean there were
there were a lot of times that the plug
wanted to be pulled and every time it
was like
even if I am holding this together
myself someone told me that like the act
of a film being made is an actual
Miracle every single time because
there's so many ways that it could just
never be made and it felt that way
certainly there were times where it was
like I have to brute force my way into
keeping this thing going
which is exhausting
not something that I always want to be
doing certainly but for the right
project
yeah something I would do again and
again gladly
did you perform this feature film live
yes we did we um
we actually had a false start in it
because
um something was like janky about the
audio on on Ellen's end I want to say
that like her airpods weren't working
so funny so we had a fall start totally
didn't work at all and so like there's
people watching right and we've already
like messed up at the beginning
and then it like cuts and it's just me a
cinematographer and Ellen being like oh
God oh God oh God oh God oh God and like
cursing and being like okay we're live
again in 30 seconds here we go doesn't
matter keep going yeah it was live oh
was it live but I mean God Alan and I
poured ourselves into that it was
exhausting we sat with those characters
for 14 months
and in the two months prior to actually
doing it live we would rehearse for a
minimum of three hours a day
it's usually longer
um and then that's that was just group
rehearsing that was in separate from
Individual rehearsing before and after
that
so from like a therapeutic standpoint by
the end of this I was like I am so sick
of suicide and I never want to talk
about it again very healing for someone
who had been struggling with that right
but um putting in all that work and all
that Sweat Equity
made it so that we really could just
trust each other and we could trust that
we had put in the work we could just be
present with each other
um and then of course like I said the
software was run in through this
platform called OBS where you're not
even like Trevor our cinematographer was
dealing with the is this matching up let
me drop in some footage what's going on
in the chat you know Sarah was meaning
the chat and we had some other celebrity
influencers coming and Manning the chat
as well so Ellen and I could just be
present and do the show start to finish
you know act by act scene by scene go
through this journey of this mother and
daughter together trying to connect
where with two very different World
Views trying to find each other find
their way back to each other and of
course the tragedy is is that they do
find their way back to each other but by
then it's too late
where else have you seen a film live
before you know done in real time almost
like a play but honestly I've never have
seen it before
I never have in my life
um
you know there's there's films like
searching where that one isn't live but
it's like it takes place on a computer
desktop right fabulous film if you
haven't seen it
um really can't recommend it enough but
in terms of seeing a film live no I'd
never seen it before like I said
artificial Bernie Sue show yes that was
live or he showed me this screamingly
funny telenovela that's on Twitch where
it's like the actors will perform a
scene and it's live and it's kind of
like sitcom right where they're they're
doing a live multi-cam taping and then
all of a sudden there's a scene break
and the audience gets to vote one of
three choices for how the story
progresses and then the actors are like
oh we're doing CNC okay here we go and
they just have to memorize three times
the amount of script based off of what
audiences could potentially choose
um
I've seen that but nothing nothing like
this not like a heavy traumatic film
that was live so in retrospect it's it's
fun to watch you know are there things I
would change yeah it was my first
feature that I produced but I'm also
immensely proud of the work my entire
team put into that thing because we were
all pioneering and figuring it out
together we were all making it up as we
go along Consulting with people sitting
with ourselves and figuring out what the
best choice would be for the story
what would you change what are some of
the things
you know we we made the choice to film
on film because we wanted to give the
flashback sequences not not for the live
taping but for the flashback sequences
specifically we filmed on 16 millimeter
and we made that choice to give it like
a grainy sort of textured um lost in my
memories type of look right like a
flashback look but the gear we we didn't
have time to really test out and get
developed and see if we needed to make
any camera adjustments and so frankly
all of that footage is pretty blurry
um which I think lends to the
storytelling and that it's like murky
and you don't know what's happening but
I would have liked to take more time to
like really do that properly you know
maybe get second camera in there so that
we could get some digital shots for
safety
and um
really flesh out how we wanted those
dropped in scenes to be
I would have liked to take more time
with that I definitely would have
changed that
um
and I would have experimented with like
can we have
multiple camera angles medium wide
close-up
um for this the sort of static shots of
Ellen and I speaking with each other so
that it felt more filmic
um you know we ended up making an
artistic choice of having both of us
side by side the entire time because
personally I feel that half of the story
is in the reactions the other person has
and so if we had edited it like a film
like she said he said she said she said
she said she said you're going to miss
half the story
um which is really how do how are these
people reacting to the words that they
hear so it is really unconventional you
know it's not a film for everybody for
sure um and definitely the festival
circuit people were like no I don't want
this film
um which is fine it's not meant to be
for everybody that's okay it reached the
people it needed to reach you know
so aside from having it premiere on
Twitch then you wanted to take it to
yeah we took it we took it on the
festival circuit and we did really well
we um I'm really happy with the festival
turnout we won a Webby award
um we even had a small Presence at can
this year so I'm I'm beyond thrilled
with how that film went I mean full
disclosure the budget for our film was
five thousand dollars so it was a
non-budget it was like a below zero
budget but to be able to have the
tracking that we got it was also a
charitable production because I wanted
to be really specific about like this is
going to go to mental health
organizations because that is what we're
all about with what we're doing but I
tracked how much we would have made if
we had actually tried to make it a
commercially viable thing and and it it
was alarmingly successful
where can someone see night mother now
you can see it on our twitch Channel
which is called night mother on Twitch
you'll you'll if you search for that
it'll come right up alternatively it's
the link in my Instagram bio so you
really can't miss it there which is
always fun to tell people who are like
where do I see it I'm like it's right
um yeah I try to keep it easily
accessible
what advice do you have for another
producer who wants to be part of a live
film
oh
[Music]
what advice do I have I guess the
biggest one is you are taking on the
challenges of both life theater and film
and be prepared for that it is going to
be twice the amount of work that you
thought it was however it's also has the
ability to let you tell a story on a on
a super budget right like it was my
budget was five thousand dollars it was
something where we could all come
together do the story tell it right and
money was not an issue which I think is
so often a challenge with Indie
filmmaking it also was like we have
built-in distribution so I don't have to
worry about going to the markets and
playing the distribution game I think a
big problem with film and other Arts is
the high barriers to entry of cost and
so finding ways to let people
authentically tell stories that matter
to them that they want to be told that
also get to like kind of Debut who they
are as an artist in a lot of ways
they're how we have to find ways that
are cost effective you know way days
where people don't necessarily have a
budget of a million dollars but their
story has Merit and they should also be
allowed to make money off of their story
should they choose you know I mean I
would just say it's a lot of work but
there are a lot of potential rewards to
doing it and I think if you pick a story
that means something to you that you
believe is going to mean something to
others then you cannot fail
how important was it to have this
audience interaction really important to
me I did not want to leave my audience
feeling unheard and uncared for I wanted
we actually had a whole post show panel
after the film specifically because and
again Sarah's brilliant idea because I
wanted it to be a ramp up I wanted I
didn't want people I mean look quite
transparently the play in the film ends
with the daughter taking her own life it
ends with a suicide so I was like do I
want to have my audience leave that
experience completely shattered
or do we want to have a panel talking
about resources talking about I'm a
celebrity and I feel sad sometimes too
talking about ways politically you can
Lobby your Senators to to advocate for
more Equitable mental health care across
this country right I wanted to make it a
platform so that people could talk about
the film afterwards with each other in
the chat right where people could feel
like they were left with a positive like
this is a community I'm a part of it I'm
going to take care of myself and maybe
I'll be brave enough to tell my story
too that's how I wanted people to leave
it
um why we did the post show panel